L'été c'est des boissons fraîches des gourmandises sucrées des roulades dans l'herbe parmi les fleurs
mais cachée derrière chacune de ces réjouissances il y a une bestiole qui pourrait bien vous faire passer un sale quart d'heure voire un peu plus.
Tout l'été DTC vous aide à éviter les pièges et les dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et votre santé
DTC partenaire de votre été
elles sont comme vous elles profitent de la nature quand l'été arrive et que le soleil donne la même couleur aux gens
gentiment oui mais voilà un cas de rencontre avec la petite bête qui pique c'est souvent la grosse bête qui pleure
on va trouver des solutions pour arranger ça
Aujourd'hui on va se concentrer sur les petites bêtes qui volent mais avant toute chose faisons connaissance
les abeilles alors y'a que les femelles qui piquent
mais attention le mâle c'est pas le bourdon on les appelle les faux-bourdons parce qu'ils ressemblent un peu à leurs cousins mais
en vrai, c'est pas les mêmes. Les bourdons
contrairement à ce qu'on pense et notamment parce que comme on vient de le voir on les confond avec des abeilles mâles les bourdons
ça pique enfin juste les femelle encore une fois d'ailleurs c'est le cas chez tous les autres hyménoptères
comme par exemple la guêpe qui peut piquer plusieurs fois contrairement à l'abeille dont l'aiguillon reste planté quand elle attaque et qui en meure
alors remballez vos théories sexistes s'il n'y a que les femelles qui piquent c'est parce qu'au fur et à mesure de leur évolution
leurs ovipositeurs qui sont des longs organes fin qui servent à pondre
se sont transformés en aiguillon et du coup comme les mâles ne pondent pas ils n'ont pas d'aiguillon
d'ailleurs les mâles n'ont pas vraiment besoin de se défendre puisqu'ils sortent assez peu vu qu'ils sont très occupés à leur principale activité : la reproduction
d'ailleurs devinez ce qu'ils ont à la place de l'aiguillon...
Vous connaissez peut-être aussi le taon un sympathique animal qui n'est pas un hyménoptère mais qui pique aussi et devinez quoi
seulement les femelles
sauf que contrairement à toutes les précédentes, elle elle ne pique pas pour se défendre mais pour nous voler  un peu de sang comme les
moustiques
sauf que la douleur n'est pas la même
bon c'est bien joli tout ça mais qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on s'est fait piqué
on commence à retirer les bagues les chaînes les bracelets les cockrings et tout autre objet qui entoure le membre piqué parce qu'il va gonfler
et que ça risque de le comprimer et qu'après ce sera trop tard pour l'enlever
ensuite si l'aiguillon est resté planté dans la peau on glisse quelque chose de fin en dessous et on le fait sauter sans appuyer
dessus parce que ça risquerait de presser sur la glande qui est restée accrochée et qui injecterait encore plus de venin. Et maintenant la solution magique
Si vous fumez allumez vous une cigarette c'est sans doute la seule situation dans laquelle ça va avoir un effet bénéfique
approchez le bout incandescent de l'endroit qui a été piqué
suffisamment près pour que la chaleur soit perceptible mais pas trop pour pas de ça brûle et attendez quelques secondes
le venin de ces petites bestioles est thermolabile c'est à dire que la chaleur l'inactive donc ça va soulager la douleur
alors on est d'accord que n'importe quel autre source de chaleur fera l'affaire, que ce soit un bout de bois incandescent, un
briquet un allume cigare un sèche cheveux voire un chanteur de charme
si vous faites piquer en pleine nature vous avez quand même pas mal plus de chance de trouver quelqu'un qui fume que quelqu'un qui se
fait un brushing ou qui danse le zouk
vous pouvez ensuite nettoyer la piqûre avec un antiseptique parce que ces petites bestioles ont la fâcheuse habitude de tremper leur dard un peu n'importe
où si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
avec le coup de la cigarette la douleur devrait avoir disparu mais si c'est pas le cas n'hésitez pas à prendre un antalgique
en cas de piqûre dans la bouche prévenez le samu au 15 parce qu'à cet endroit là si ça se met à gonfler ça va
empêcher l'air de passer quelque soit la zone piquée prévenait aussi le 15 en cas de démangeaisons importantes dans tout le corps et de
difficultés respiratoires qui sont des films de réactions allergiques
si tout va bien vous pouvez faire un saut chez le pharmacien en rentrant de votre petite balade et lui demander quelque chose à mettre sur
la piqûre pour apaiser faire dégonfler et calmer les démangeaisons
pommade, gel, plante, huiles essentielles, il y en a pour tous les goûts dans les jours suivants si l’œdème, c'est à dire le
gonflement ne disparaît pas ou si de la fièvre et des frissons apparaissent il faut consulter un médecin pour vérifier qu'il n'y a pas une infection
avant de se quitter et parce que rien ne remplace la prévention deux ou trois conseils pour éviter de se faire piquer éviter de marcher
pieds nus dans l'herbe pour éviter de marcher sur une bestiole en train de cultiver nous faire sa sieste posée mettez-vous à sa place si
on vous marchez dessus pendant votre bain de soleil et vous aviez un gros dard, vous aussi vous en serviriez
méfiez-vous des canettes et pas le bébé du canard, le truc pour boire. La fraîcheur et le sucre ça attire tout ce petit monde
et s'il y a une petite bête qui est en train de boire un coup au fond de ce que vous vous êtes en train de boire
vous risquez de vous faire piquer versez votre boisson dans un verre et soyez vigilent. Les taons préfèrent la peau mouillée
alors séchez vous en sortant de l'eau quand vous vous êtes baignés. Pour finir on dit aussi que les vêtements de couleurs vives attirent
les hyménoptères parce qu'ils les prennent pour des fleurs mais bon on va pas s'empêcher d'avoir du swag  quand même
voila DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans 15 jours pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là portez vous bien.